we're now heading into December 2019
just one more month left in this year
and I guess you could say in the decade
as well we're about to enter the 2020s
so it's time for another monthly update
video in which I'll talk about what went
on in the month of November and what
we've got coming up for you here in
December so if you missed anything this
is the chance to find out about it and
I'll put links to everything below that
I'm referencing in the video description
all you have to do is click the show
more seam or whatever it happens to be
in your YouTube interface so I always
like to begin by talking about three big
things that I think are worth
highlighting the first one is that we've
got a suggestions and then a vote coming
up for the worlds of speculative fiction
series so if you want to get in on
helping to decide three authors that I
will be adding to the 2020 talk series
you want to get in on that I'll tell you
more about that in the December portion
the second big thing is that I will be
doing a guest appearance as a show host
for one of our local radio stations
helping out with their fund and pledge
drive we'll be doing a show focused on
practical philosophy probably on
generosity on giving things like that
you know to get people interested in
giving to the station so I'll talk more
about that in December as well and then
the third big thing is more global the
semester is finally winding down we have
effectively two more weeks of class for
most of the places that I'm teaching in
this incredibly pett semester and I
think many of you know that this
semester has been kind of a rough one
just in terms of the sheer volume of
work involved
I taught seven classes I'm still
teaching seven classes right now so once
those things are off my docket I can I
can concentrate a lot more on the sort
of things that you know me for the
videos that I haven't gotten to that I
wanted to and some of the other public
events that I've been aiming to do but
all the course class commitments have
kind of held me back so those are the
three big things let's talk now about
what happened in November November was a
rather busy month were now in the very
last day of our Thanksgiving break and
it was so packed that I found that I
really needed to take a break by the end
of it and so I'm now getting back to
doing some work today but I haven't been
doing too much for the last several days
we didn't go anywhere for Thanksgiving
we just stayed here and chilled out and
enjoyed ourselves and took it easy so I
did have some events earlier on in
November at the beginning of the month
we finished up year four of the
philosophers in the midst of history
with a session on Simone de Beauvoir so
you can see the video for that if you
look down below click this show more and
you'll see all of the links for these
various videos and things we also did
what is a session 41 in the worlds of
speculative fiction monthly series and
this time we focused on Bram Stoker had
a really great conversation about
Dracula a little bit about layer the
white worm and talked a bit about his
biography but mostly focusing on Dracula
and some of the philosophical themes and
implications I also did a interview
video with Nathan Ormond who is starting
a new series and we talked we were going
to talk mostly about seeing handsome but
we actually ended up talking a lot about
the nature of Christian philosophy and
academic philosophy and philosophy as a
way of life and we also did talk quite a
bit about and some of Canterbury's
somebody who I do a lot of research on
and then of course
there's the videos you know from the the
usual online events that I do they have
our Hegel q and A's the ask me anything
session what else
you know the philosophy chat all of
those sorts of things that we do
regularly and we had a really great
Milwaukee stoic fellowship where we we
got to talk about a lot of interesting
stuff and start doing a little bit of
planning for the year ahead in addition
to teaching my seven classes which all
of which have a significant online
component some of which are entirely
online
so the require shooting videos
developing resources doing a lot of
grading i also engaged in some tutoring
and some philosophical counseling and
i'm still doing some ethics consulting
work here in the air i get tapped by
local and international organizations
for that i managed to get the podcast up
and running again and released some some
episodes on aristotle that i needed to
edit for quite a while Aristotle's
metaphysics book 1 once we finished up
with that I started into editing
episodes on real case letters to a young
poet and we're not quite finished with
those I still have I think one more of
those to release and then we're gonna
move on to other podcast episodes and
when it comes to videos I didn't manage
to get to the book reviews I also didn't
manage to get to the half-hour Haegele
commentary video and I didn't get to the
self-directed study unfortunately they
got bogged down a bit between illnesses
family obligations classes clients all
that I just couldn't get to all of that
but now I'm refreshed and ready to jump
into it
I did get some core concept videos done
on AJ Ayers language truth and logic
that I've been releasing and I shot a
few on David Humes inquiry concerning
human understanding and I'd of course
released quite a few descartes videos
earlier in the month as well on
meditations five and six
and there's the videos from the public
events the one on de Beauvoir the one on
Bram Stoker and there's the video about
the worlds of speculative fiction asking
you to give suggestions which will lead
up to a vote coming up this this month
of December December is another holiday
month so there's a good bit of time that
gets shaved off for engaging in family
stuff my kids will be visiting here
which will be quite nice over the
Christmas break and my daughter is
coming up for an audition and I'll be
going down as well for attending one of
my kids concerts so I'm gonna get to see
them quite a lot this month which again
is always quite nice but it does involve
a good bit of travel another thing
that's that's really quite cool coming
up this month a personal first for me
and a third I think for my wife is that
we are going to be going to see the
Packers play at Lambeau Field so that
that's kind of a big thing we're
fortunate in that we're not that far
away from Green Bay to you know where it
would be like a four to five hour drive
as it would be for some people in the
state not to mention people out of state
but you know it's still a good trek up
there
particularly during winter weather and
it's like a whole experience so we've
got some some cool stuff lined up for
that I'm really looking forward to
seeing what game is like on the field
the last time that I saw the Packers
play I was probably 15 years old and it
was down here in Milwaukee because they
used to play at County Stadium some of
their home games so you know us rest of
the state would easily get to see them
and a friend of mine his his parents had
tickets and took me along also went once
with my dad when I was a kid as well so
it's been quite a long time
and that is those are some cool things
coming up now well you're probably more
interested in is hearing about events
that that are coming up here's the
calendar so on the 7th at 12 p.m. we're
gonna have our AMA that has asked me
anything session we do that online you
can just log in you'll see it pop up on
my youtube channel so you want to my
youtube channel open around 12 p.m.
Central Time and then you can jump in
ask us whatever questions you've got on
your mind and I may or may not be able
to get to them I try to do first-come
first-serve but you know we get so many
questions that by the end I just have to
sort of pick and choose on the 12th at
at 7 p.m. if you're here locally we will
be having session 42 of the worlds of
speculative fiction series this on our
Scott Bacher's second apocalypse
officially it's on the Prince of nothing
trilogy but I went ahead and read the
other four books so over the last about
a month and a half
I've been reading my way through his
work Bakker is actually a trained
philosopher and there are some really
really cool themes going on in his his
books I won't say anything that's a
spoiler other to say that you know the
world-building is is extremely extensive
and I'm really looking forward to it on
the 14th at 12 p.m. we will finally have
that video premiere of the self-directed
study Sandler's advice early christian
philosophy I wasn't able to get to shoot
the video this this month unfortunately
but I will be able to shoot it in the
coming week or so and that'll be that'll
be good because it will have that lined
up for you also on the 14th at 2:00 p.m.
I'll be having the philosophy chat for
patreon supporters that's a perk at a
certain level of patreon support on the
17th now this is one of the things I
talked about in the three big things on
the 17th at 10 p.m.
full-time I will be going on Riverwest
radio live with hopefully a guest
co-host Dan Hayes and we're gonna be
talking about practical philosophy and
answering some you know questions and
queries and problems that viewers like
you might might be adding to it I'll put
a call out in social media for that but
it's we're really gonna be trying to
raise money for Riverwest radio it's a
local community station for River West
Milwaukee they I've been on quite a few
of their shows as a guest and they
really do a lot of great work so you can
tune in to them and listen live as I go
on the show on the 18th at 5:00 p.m.
will have our Hagel public Q&A and
discussion session so if you've got
questions about Hagel German idealism
philosophy in general you can video
conference with me I'll put you know
links for that there as well and on the
19th the last event of the month will be
6:00 p.m. here in Milwaukee
the Milwaukee stoic fellowship which
meets in person at the Shorewood Public
Library where we'll be discussing what
we've got coming up the year ahead
talking about what we did with our you
know monthly practice and about Marcus
Aurelius is meditations which we're
reading our way through so a lot of cool
stuff coming up here in the local area
you know I continue with with tutoring
and philosophical counseling and
consulting my classes will end you know
halfway through the month and then
there's the grading to take care of
there's always a lot of that and then I
you know I'm gearing up for the new year
we're putting events on the calendar for
speaking engagements I'm already getting
some queries about that by the way if
you're interested in having me come talk
or provide a workshop at your
organization or institution send me an
email Gregg at reason I Oh calm and
we'll talk about it now is the time to
get in on it because as the time goes on
my event my events calendar starts
filling up if you're interested in
starting some philosophical counseling
or tutoring or something like that begin
the New Year right well then you want to
contact me about that as well because my
calendar like I think I just mentioned
does fill up and they're quickly
I'm also you know getting ready to start
offering more workshops here locally
which which i think is going to be a fun
thing and what else do we got going on
oh you know I'm doing some writing
projects not so much this month more
just doing the preparatory work for that
but I've already put in a proposal for a
local conference here with a guest with
a co-writer co-author somebody who I
enjoy working with quite a bit so doing
a little bit of academic stuff as well
for the podcast I will be releasing the
Rilke the last Rilke one later on today
most likely and then I'm gonna start
going into those on decart's meditations
eventually we'll have about you know
20-something podcast episodes going
through that entire work and then if we
have time which we probably won't but
you know let's let's just say we're
being optimistic here and I turn out
like one a day then we'll get into
Nietzsche's truth and lies in an extra
moral sense and you know start releasing
those as well I know people have been
asking for Nietzsche videos so we've got
more air core concept videos coming up I
also shot a sequence on James from my
students that'll be early releasing to
my patreon supporters and then releasing
to the general public if I have time
over the course of the month I'm going
to shoot the ones on Vidkun Stein on
just parts of his philosophical
investigations
that I teach in my classes that I think
need to be done and then you know this
month is going to be the month when I
get to the half hour Hegel videos and
start churning those out I did a lot of
reading and rereading but I just didn't
have the time to get in front of the
track board and start shooting them and
there's the self directed study video as
well on Christian philosophy that I'm
going to shoot this week and then we'll
do that like I said the video premiere
on the 14th and finally one of the
things that I have been meaning to do
for quite a while
book reviews I'm gonna get some of those
done this month and I've got some of the
books here that I'm going to get out of
my stack including one that's a library
book so you've seen these series hot as
that little thing that's you know got
the the Latin or Greek on facing pages
released by Princeton University Press
right so this is Cicero's how to be a
friend basically the day I'm a kid see I
write and we're gonna talk about that
I've got a couple stoic books that got
sent to me a while back that I need to
work my way through and give reviews of
a better human by George Bradley the
stoic CEO by Al kissed this doesn't even
have her name on the thing for getting
her her last name
in any case should be interesting and
then one I've been wanting to review for
a long time attending the epicurean
garden by Hyrum Crespo who's by the way
is just to the south of us here in the
Chicagoland area and then one that I'm
reading my way through right now which
is along the same lines and it was
released recently Kathryn Wilson's how
to be an epicurean so it's rather
ambitious to say I'm gonna do five but
let's let's give it a shot anyway so
that's it for the month like I said you
know make sure to tune in to the
Riverwest radio show 10:00 p.m. central
the 17th and if you're in the area and
you want to come to the stoic fellowship
or to the worlds of speculative fiction
discussion about our Scott Bakker make
sure that you do and otherwise stay
tuned I've got a lot of content coming
out this month hope all of you have a
great holiday season and enjoy yourself
and get to spend some time with people
who you enjoy and I'll see you in some
of the online events or in social media
you